voilà
voilà sarah abitbol et stéphane bernadis
nous racontait interview vérité
donc c'est un rêve qui s'écroule après
vingt ans de patinage je vais jamais été
blessé aussi gravement sa non je n'ai
jamais été blessé quelques petites
entorses avec dix quinze jours d'arrêt
mais vraiment rien rien de grave
ouais le problème que vous avez stéphane
c'est comme on peut le dire parce qu'on
le sait cet ensemble dans la vie pouvait
pas trouver une autre équipe hier vous
non et puis j'ai signé avec elle les le
départ et puis voilà c'est comme ça avec
un fils de toute façon bien brillant
alors on est obligé de le faire avec
donc je m'entraîne tout seul un peu
triste mais c'est comme ça en plus c'est
elle qui vous tire est d'une certaine
façon commencent à dire que maintenant
alors c'est vrai que non on peut le dire
c'est vrai sarah une plus grande soif de
réussite que vous seul pouvez toujours
aller de l'avant donc c'est vrai qu'elle
est
et elle est très meneuse et nous a fait
quand même quelque chose qu'elle se
blesse comme ça ouais vous dites
d'ailleurs sarah mater sortir de mon
trou grâce à elle je suis devenu
quelqu'un donc pour ça que disent ah
ouais c'est vrai que fait sortir de mon
trou suivant une berge professeur bigard
way qui profite du mois elle peut pas
trop bouger allez-y fait que le matin
alors dès votre arrivée à paris vous
avez été admise à l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière vous été opéré par le
professeur saillant
donc je suis qui avait opéré ronaldo je
me c'est vrai oui j'étais dans ma
chambre juste à côté c'était même ça
change ça faisait un mois et demi de
plâtre avant de commencer la rééducation
et vous d'un dévouement absolu vous
passez vos nuits à ses côtés pendant le
temps où elle est à l'hôpital de la
salpêtrière mais disons que je
m'attendais à vivre le plus beau jour de
ma vie j'ai vécu le pire
donc c'était très difficile et qu'il
soit à mes côtés à mon chevet lors de
l'opération il était un hôpital après il
est resté avec moi toute la nuit c'était
quelque chose moi très bien aurait pu
manquer que c'est vrai qu'il va y faire
la révolte 1
ouais hein oui puis remarqué quand on a
touché le fond on peut que remonter
après toute façon que je me tue online
bah ouais on s'attaque à la maintenance
des remontées bien ceux qui cherchent un
bon viendra ici en le problème c'est que
c'est malheureusement pas fini puisque
l'annoncé tardive de votre forfait
aurait permis aurait permis un didier
gailhaguet le patron de la fédération
française de maintenir la juge française
marie-reine le gougne et c'est elle qui
contre toute évidence a déclaré
les russes vainqueurs au détriment des
canadiens bien conseillé non mais nous
notre problème principal quand sarah été
blessé ça a été de la faire rapatrier
très rapidement parce qu'on nous a dit
qu'elle pouvait pas rester comme ça et
notre forfait
c'est à la salle donc à partir de là
ceux qui s'occupent aussi tardivement la
déclaration de votre forfait alors
demandé malheureusement kayak et oui
parce qu'on parle d'arrangements entre
la france où le savez entre la france et
le bloc de l'est pour faire gagner le
couple tricolore
gwendal peizerat et marina anissina ce
qui arrive quelques jours plus tard
s'est déclenché un scandale énorme enfin
tout le monde tout le monde a parlé
c'est le cas de le dire
protestations du canada enquête les
russes hurle en disant qu'on est revenu
au temps de la guerre froide
ça devient une affaire d'état basset a
rarement est en fait autant de scandales
et je n'ai je donc j'espère que tout va
pas se régler parce que ça salit un
petit peu l'image de nos sports qui bien
sûr qui est pourtant magnifique on est
vraiment des laits des vrais sportifs
s'entraînent de six heures par jour et
c'est c'est dur de devoir entrer dans
les jt entre nous croient qu'il a fait
exprès gailhaguet de pas signifier tout
de suite votre forfait pour pouvoir
garder
marie-reine le gougne qui elle allait
voter évidemment pour les russes qui eux
après aller voter pour les français
franchement choses bizarres on peut pas
on ne peut pas prenez enfin c'est pas
qu'on n'est pas au courant mais s'ils ne
veulent rien faire
on était dans un contexte qui nous
permet de toute façon de dépasser apple
c'est sûr ils font du sport six heures
par jour
des sportifs sont pas des businessmen
qui non mais bon il ya eu des pressions
d'ailleurs marie-reine le gougne dit
avoir dans un premier temps elle dit
j'ai favorisé virus elle avoue avoir
favorisé les russes sur instruction de
monsieur gailhaguet et après elle s'est
rétractée mais enfin bon
il avait subi des pressions de
gailhaguet et d'ailleurs finalement le
cio et le comité olympique international
a donné également une médaille d'or aux
canadiens ça va finir comme chef jacques
martin tout le monde en a 10 c'est le
seul point positif de la faire c'est
qu'à une nouvelle façon de juger
maintenant donc au lieu de neuf juges
viennent aura 14 c'est mieux c'est moins
bien et moins bien par tout le monde
c'est l'ordinateur qui choisira
l'ordinateur choisira qu'elle juge ne
sont parfaits
du coup les juges ils pourront très bien
mettre une note très bas si on ne dira
pas leur nom encore pire
oui ça permettra à toutes les tricheries
ce coup ci fait pas tout et tricherie
mais disons que je pense que lles eu
l'international skating l'une a fait ça
pour pour ne pleurent des problèmes avec
les justes et on pourra plus on ne
pourra plus prendre au juge pourtant il
ça a été fait ça on sent vraiment à
l'ordinateur
voilà encore moins été sacré la cellule
quand elle va rembourser c'est la faute
aux ordinateurs et ça c'est lamentable
parce que sur l'ordinateur il écarte des
juges honnêtes et qu'il garde et cilou
ce sera encore pire que c'est n'importe
quoi je pense pas que je mangeais de
fans que ça ne va pas de voter alors
faut dire quand même une chose c'est que
derrière les sourires et les paillettes
le patinage c'est un monde assez dur ça
peut se régler à coups de couteau tu
souvient de la sphère kerrigan harding
et vous peut dire aussi il ya un an
j'étais victime d'un coup de cutter la
veille d'une compétition dans une
chambre d'hôtel
championnats du monde à nice voilà j'ai
enfin me regarder la télé on sonne coups
de cutter ou vers le bras sans en
demander
j'ai pris un coup j'ai la porte s'est
refermée elle se referme automatiquement
et
j'ai vu une silhouette mais
malheureusement j'ai mené en plein coup
de cutter et depuis peu un coup de fil
plus rien c'était l'un d'eux aussi des
plus beau jour de notre vie sportive qui
sont assez quatrième après le programme
court on jouait le podium c'était du
championnat du monde en france l'anif
donc on se pose des questions
ouais hélas la voilà on voit la nature
le sahara bitbol dit tant pis faut
patiner faut y aller voilà et oui
j'étais allé vous avez gagné voilà c'est
extraordinaire ont besoin et donc donc
ça va ça s'est arrangé
c'était très bien mais stéphane était à
deux doigts de tout lâcher il arrête il
n'arrêtait pas de pleurer il m'a dit
comment je vais faire pour te porter
comment je vais faire mais bon on a fait
une piqûre et santé - son bras il a pu
me porter mais c'était vraiment un
moment très difficile est d'avoir gagné
la nôtre vis un roman-feuilleton la
bulgare 48 heures avant bercy
il est sûr à scooter il ya une gonzesse
qui pile devant lui il tape un nom mais
j'essaye moi j'ai c'est dur mais je suis
très sensible à ce qui est arrivé à
sarah parce que c'est c'est terrible
comme de se préparer pendant toute une
vie
et puis de se péter le tendon d'achille
est comme moi je pense que il faut
trouver quelque chose de bien tout ce
qui arrive et là j'ai vraiment du mal
pour eux là je me dis qu vraiment ou
alors je me dis bien que c'est vrai que
dans deux ans ils vont
savez-vous top niveau et qui va
peut-être y arrive et à sang on peut
plus rien changer à ce qui s'est passé
et on peut pas les annuler les jeux bah
non c'est trop tard bien avalé le taux
est maintenant d'ailleurs voudrais
remercier de sa rare sur façade moi ça
m'a beaucoup étonné mais des centaines
des centaines de lettres de gens qui
nous ont écrit et donc je voulais leur
dire que s'ils veulent avoir des
nouvelles de saramon l'incitent notre
site qui s'appelle hiver.com egloff on
attend des nouvelles tous les jours de
sarah donc voilà je vais vous dire un
truc c'est pour ça que vous êtes là ce
soir c'est que je vous ai vu à la télé
quand il est arrivé à l'aéroport j'ai vu
votre tête et jeudi à catherine barma
faut vraiment qu'on les invite tout
s'est écroulé d'un coup on reste
s'écrouler sans le moment c'était
vraiment très dur d'ailleurs d'en
reparler c'est difficile mais bon j'ai
mon rêve maintenant c'est devenir
championne d'europe championne du monde
et peut-être championne olympique en
j'espère que je n'aurai plus mal avec la
niaque que vous avez vous aider à y
arriver on va vous applaudir le fils
non
normal en vapeur pardon j'ai oublié de
dire c'est son baron dette ou des
eaux-bonnes anniversaire encore e blu
merci restez avec nous vous êtes ainsi
je vais bien toute façon en mal on va
passer au jeu